everybody we're back tony v very funny
guy is going to be out here in just a
second but first it's time to introduce
a new segment on our show we're all very
excited about it
it's the late night salmon grab
all right folks uh here's how it works
in this tank right here
is a real live pacific salmon flown to
us
at great expense from the state of
washington
now folks here's what's going to happen
i'm going to ask for one volunteer from
the audience
just a typical random audience member
and that lucky person is going to come
down here and see if he or she can grab
the salmon
with their teeth now folks if that
person succeeds
we have a couple of great prizes
standing by
it sounds pretty tough i mean to grab a
salmon with your teeth and
they move fast well andy i think someone
in the audience
is going to be up to it okay now uh liz
why don't we just turn the cameras
around see if we have any volunteers at
all anybody who's interested in
salmon and uh let's see just a random
person in the audience
that's great yeah how about you sir
right there that's terrific you sir
right there
that's terrific okay
[Applause]
what's up man dale westbrook
i'm psyched to be here totally oh look
at him
yeah but i meant to choose all right so
what do i do just get in there and grab
the sandwich with my teeth right
um yeah cool uh
you got it wow do you really you really
you really want to do it
because i dude i love fish let's get it
on
yeah i'm coming for ya
all right uh max drum roll please all
[Music]
[Applause]
right
well um would you win okay well we had
two prizes lined up for you
okay you know but i don't i don't
i don't think you're gonna like them so
what are you talking about anything's
cool i'll take it
all right well your first prize
is an actual live beehive giving him a
beehive
oh yes
you're all right huh you're okay
okay all right what's my next prize um
i don't think it's such a good idea man
we'll just stick with that i'm talking
about
i love to be hot
i think you got to do it i mean what the
hell all right
all right your other prize is a date
with the sexiest gal in town i'm
talking of course about none other than
griselda grizzly
big date with uh
oh wow i've always wanted to have sex
with a bear
[Applause]
this is great all right we're gonna take
a little break uh
maybe we'll try this again sometime a
different way tony v is coming up stick
around